[Music]
[Applause]
david carr nfl network analyst former
nfl quarterback you can follow him on
twitter at d car eight this sunday a
special six-hour edition of nfl game day
morning airs at 9 eastern on nfl network
david thanks for joining us what do you
think sean payton is going to do
sit at home go to a tailgate
i think he's tired
i also think that the cap
the cap issues in new orleans might have
forced this as well i mean when you
watched him you know he's such a good
play caller and it's just hard because
you know going back between you know
taysom hill gonna be the quarterback you
know who's gonna be who's gonna be the
guy and he's he's so good that they they
still almost got in the playoffs you
know great defense yeah but
man what he did you know just from a
quarterback standpoint and i guess
coach's standpoint watching it from afar
it's brilliant man the guys the guy's
incredible so let him take his let him
take his time go to a couple tailgates
enjoy yourself and then
and then get back in the thing i i think
i think the the league's better if he's
calling place he's great i think that uh
you're on to something with the salary
cap obviously but i think he looked at
the quarterbacking situation and thought
i can't i can't compete not with this
and i mean he tried to get drew brees to
come back for this season they somehow
squeezed out nine wins and they didn't
even have michael thomas there
okay man you watched two space aliens
played quarterback in kansas city the
other day it's like i don't have that
i
guy
supposed to win another super bowl so i
think he's i think that probably helped
could you see him coaching the cowboys
and they trade for sean payton yeah
yeah i can't i just uh i just don't know
if it'll be this year i kind of i kind
of feel like it is going to be
at least one more year with mike
mccarthy and and then if that goes south
i think jerry jones is going to be jerry
jones has wanted sean payton forever he
i mean he wanted to be their coach for a
long time i mean i came back when i was
with the giants and that that noise
would swirl around oh sean payton's
coming back to dallas i'm like what do
you mean why you know and so it's just
like one of those things he's always
he's always wanted sean to be the coach
there and i think i think jerry jones
will do everything he can to get him to
go
you know we have a couple of teams that
feels like are in quarterbacking limbo i
don't know if the 49ers know what they
have with trey lance and it looks like
they're going to move on from jimmy
garoppolo the titan situation with ryan
tannehill can he take you only so far
carson wentz with the colts maybe the
vikings with kirk cousins
what do you do in those situations if
you're not quite sure you have that guy
who is a special quarterback or can take
you to the next level
i think you have to make a move the
problem is like i referenced earlier
watching josh allen and pat moms throw
the ball around the other day every
coach is looking at that situation like
well we need one of those guys well
guess what there's only two of them on
the planet so that's not gonna happen
you know you gotta you have to find a
guy that will that will fit we we saw
tom brady for two and a half decades now
pretty much dominate from the
quarterback standpoint and he can't move
outside the tackle box so it's like and
and arm strength wise and arm
talent-wise it doesn't even compare to
those guys so there's still ways to win
um
in the national football league not
having one of those players but but if
you have a guy that's that's holding you
back like you watch kyle shanahan call
plays like and i know jimmy garoppolo
has a great winning percentage i know
all those things right but i also know
that he turned matt ryan into an mvp and
he hasn't sniffed that trophy since i
know that kyle shanahan from a schematic
standpoint is is so much
further ahead and he puts you in such a
better position than you would be just
on your own or just with another
offensive coordinator that i almost
throw the winning percentage out because
yeah jimmy's got to play better they got
to find a way to be better at that
position or be cheaper if you can't be
better and be one of those elite guys
you got to go you got to grab a young
guy and you have one in your house so
it's going to be interesting man you
know we were spinning around the table
me and steve mariucci were talking about
this because he's season ticket holder
with the packers that's kind of weird
still
the head coach of the 49ers and and he
was saying did you think what i was
thinking and and and i already knew
where he was going the packers if they
keep aaron rodgers they're 40 something
million dollars you know cap hit
they let him go they save 16 or
something
trade into san francisco for two firsts
and trey lance and then everyone's happy
and kyle shanahan and matt lafleur
buddies they can make that thing happen
over some chipotle like just make it
happen you know so i think that
that's going to be a scenario
i can't imagine
uh jimmy garoppolo being back to san
francisco he's done great and maybe
he'll just surprise everybody and
they'll go in the super bowl that'd be
fantastic but i still think
it would be a situation where
um you want to inspire your quarterback
i can't imagine that green bay would
want to trade him and keep him in the
nfc and trade him to the 49ers i thought
he's crazy too i thought we started
talking about it he's like but
you almost you would think that would be
the last place right but where is it
where's aaron from he's from san
francisco he's from that area right he
would love to go back there um i just
think it makes it just makes it makes
almost too much sense just from a cap
standpoint and what you know what both
teams could benefit because i don't
think green bay is happy with him either
you think you watch how aaron walked out
of that stadium he just kind of he just
kind of hit a little wave and everybody
just stared at him it's like all right
we won 13 games three years in a row and
what do we have to show for it nothing
except our quarterback that our fans
normally go on you know so something's
got to change david carr nfl network
analyst former nfl quarterback i'm
watching joe burrow somehow survive nine
sacks david
how does that happen it's never happened
before in in playoffs
never happened before in nfl playoff
history
nine sacks when you win a game
i got sacked nine times once i did not
beat the number one seed in the playoffs
in their stadium we got blown out in san
diego by the chargers in junior seas so
that that just is not something that
happens you know and for him to keep
getting up and firing back you know it
was it was really interesting with the
bengals because
they obviously have tremendous talent on
the outside joe mixon's special back
joe is obviously talented or you just
don't do what he did but man when i
watch them
from a schematic standpoint and a
protection standpoint tennessee and they
had nine sacks and but that wasn't just
getting physically beat they had issues
dude like up front they weren't blocking
anybody they were sliding the wrong way
they were a disaster it literally
reminded me of the the texans in my
first year like that's how bad it looks
and and oh by the way they won the game
you know so they have to fix those
things and that it's not on it's not on
just one guy but zach taylor and
callahan they got to be better they have
to have answers because there's times
when there's free rushers coming at joe
burrow and there's three receivers that
he's looking to on one side that are
running with their back to him look no
one's looking no one's adjusting so they
have to fix that
or they're going to get tested big time
against kansas city steve stragnolo is
going to do exactly what tennessee did
and and so on so my fear and i'm not
like i'm not hating on the bengals i'm
happy that they've done this i i just
can see like the writing on the wall
that if they i'm afraid that joe is
going to be so good
that he's going to cover up a lot of
sins and they're not going to be as
successful as they should be with him at
quarterback so we'll see hopefully i'm
wrong and hopefully they can fix this
stuff i don't know if they can fix it
this year
we'll see how far they can go but they
do have to address it for sure when you
look at the 49ers in the last 15 days
they trailed the rams 17 to nothing came
back to win in los angeles found a way
to win at dallas and then found a way to
win at green bay
they are 6-0 against the rams uh since
new year's 2019
how did the rams turn this around and
win this game
well the rams were up on them last time
i i really think that the 49ers it's a
throwback style of football it's a very
physical style of football uh but it's
it's schematically it's advantageous
because they'll put trent williams at
fullback we saw the man coming across
the
formation and just blowing up the entire
right side of the line so he does have
so many things
to challenge you so it's not like you
can just bring an extra guy down you
know what's going to have to happen is
they're going to have to just toughen up
like it's a it's old school and it's
like almost junior high-ish but you're
going to need a rah-rah speech to get
these guys physically going because
george kittle and trent williams and
these guys are going to just try and
absolutely road grade you off the line
like it was a great matchup for the rams
last week because you have a depleted
offensive line with the bucks and you
have some absolute killers up front you
got vaughn you had a great day aaron
donald these guys can just pin their
ears back and go get you right
the the what the rams have to do is they
kind of have to match they got to use
those backs you know they have cam acres
they got sonny michelle and they've been
doing a better job of that and i think
that that's where they have to go they
can't get into just a drop back pass um
situation because you know boasting
those guys armstead they'll just they're
gonna they're gonna they're gonna win
that situation they're gonna win that
battle but their edge is who they
brought in in the off season it's matt
stafford like we we saw matt's as good
as anybody in that i've seen um against
the blitz and what do we see
tampa bay do at the end of the game they
bring pressure he burns them and and he
did it consistently so
i don't know that um you know the niners
sniders aren't going to have to blitz or
they they normally don't need blitz
right exactly exactly so the only
problem is
you know can the secondary which i think
jamiko ryan has been brilliant i think
that he did a great job against aaron
rodgers it's very subtle you saw um josh
norman jog out there and you saw aaron
rodgers eyes light up like i'm coming at
this guy right and he got the first one
he threw it right at him incomplete the
second play that josh norman was in he
looked at devonte and they subtly
changed the coverage they showed like a
two-man coverage where he's being
doubled and then right at the snap josh
norman jumped outside and the safety
rotated down and aaron didn't know what
he was seeing and he went back to the
other side ended up having a thing it
wasn't a sack but it was a negative play
and that's what that's what they have to
that's what they're going to have to do
damico ryan's gonna have to be on it but
you know i think the rams can i think
the rams are gonna make a much better
game out of it because like i said they
were up they had the confidence they
could do it um but man it's the physical
it's the physicalness it's the the
physicality that they bring it's debo
samuel i mean how do you
how do you match that that's not
something that you can just flip a
switch on and and be you know you have
to be that from the beginning and that's
what that's been you know why she tends
to have been so successful all right
we've asked everybody everybody seems to
be talking about it uh your solution for
overtime in the nfl playoffs is what
well
i mean my goodness i i've known josh
allen forever and so i'm i'm a little
biased because the kids from the central
valley and i just watched him sitting on
the heater you know the whole overtime
and didn't even get a crack at it we
even heard andy reid i think yesterday
say at least let the other offense get
the ball and i understand they don't
want to do
the
college overtime for whatever reason
probably a lot of reasons they don't
want to do just a time limit another
quarter because you know that's just
going to prolong everything and that's
going to bleed into other games so i get
it so
but at least josh allen has to touch the
football for me because that'd be like
going to a dodger game right and it's
extra innings and the visiting team hits
a home run and then everybody that's it
all right everybody go home you know
like you the dogs get to hit but we're
not going to let them they don't get to
bat that's exactly what it is so i think
that you at least give the chance
for the the other team to touch the
football on offense and then
if they don't make it
then they don't make it everybody's
happy but it was a great game but it was
it left a little sour taste in your
mouth just because it you didn't feel
like you got
it it was a fair fight
thank you david we appreciate you
getting up early uh for us and uh have
fun this weekend how's your brother
doing
he's good man he's a little tired from
that season emotionally but uh he was uh
they had a good run they did pretty much
all they could do so yeah he's
he's uh he's feeling great playing a lot
of golf now and who's he think the coach
is going to be
well he'd love for it to be rich versace
honestly okay every player in that
building would love for that to be him
so
we'll see i mean we'll see we don't know
what mark's thinking and what they're
going to do and general manager's got to
get hired first but
yeah he'd love for it to be rich thank
you david we appreciate your time as
always have fun this weekend
you got it buddy thanks that's david
carr nfl network analyst he's good
there's some good opinions there i like
talking to them